Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
Agents of SHIELD made a huge callback to the
Howling Commandos and filled in all of Ward
and Garrett’s backstories.
There was also a lot of foreshadowing for
people releasing secret power inside of them.
Which means we could see some full on super
hero action in the finale next week.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do weekly videos for Marvel and Agents of
SHIELD, be sure to subscribe to get everything.
When SHIELD goes off the air I’m going to
fill this spot with Star Wars videos.
So let’s talk about some Howling Commandos
and Flashbacks.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet.
Here are my top 5 WTF moments.
Number 5 - Garrett Recruits Ward For HYDRA.
We finally found how Garrett ‘rescued’
Ward from that Bad Situation.
I actually thought he killed his brother in
that house fire but more importantly, I think
he convincingly lied about trying to kill
his brother.
I don’t know why the SHIELD Agents had to
break into Juvie like they were breaking him
out of prison.
Maybe Garrett was too lazy to spend the time
doing the necessary paperwork.
The funniest part was when Garrett dumped
him in the middle of nowhere Wyoming and told
him to survive.
It reminded me of when How I Met Your Mother
showed Robin Scherbatsky’s Sweet 16 flashback.
Played by Cobie Smulders AKA Maria Hill.
She got dropped out of a helicopter and forced
to fight off packs of rabid wolves and horny
miners.
Does that mean that Maria Hill is a bigger
badass than Ward?
Pretty much.
I know we saw his dog in the crosshairs at
the end.
I think they want to leave the possibility
of Ward getting a redemption arc.
If we had seen him straight up kill it, I
think that would be a much harder sell.
And he didn’t even really kill Fitz and
Simmons.
He just dropped them out of the sky in a glass
container, Loki Avengers Style.
If only they had Thor’s Hammer to bust out
with.
Number 4 - Howling Commando Antiques Roadshow
This was definitely the most fun scene aside
from maybe them breaking into Cybertek.
In case you forgot, Tripplett’s grandfather
was a Howling Commando and technically so
was Nick Fury, but they’re playing it fast
and loose with the timelines.
Nick Fury was probably one in the 60s and
70s.
I wonder if he ever fought with Triplett’s
grandfather?
Here’s the items I heard Coulson geeking
out over: A hand held hypno beam, a transistorized
blaster gun, the joy buzzer EMP and the grapling
gun that they used to zip line onto the train
in the first Captain America movie.
Just based on that I’d bet Tripplett’s
grandfather was on the team around the same
time.
Don’t be surprised if we get more references
to Coulson’s love of memorabilia.
I can totally see him playfighting with action
figures when no one else is around.
Pew Pew.
That’s actually one big flashback we haven’t
seen yet.
A Coulson flashback to when Nick Fury first
took him under his wing.
Number 3 - Garrett was the first Deathlok
In case you didn’t know the comic book version
of the character is a cyborg.
Not a Deathlok cyborg like on the show, but
we got a peek at his metal plating last week.
He’s basically on the edge of death, just
because his body was so far gone when he first
started the program.
This was the big plan reveal, Coulson kind
of figured it out with his chart porn but
Garrett explains it explicitly.
He needs the serum to live.
He’s only got 1 to 2 months to live.
I was so happy that they gave us that Garrett
flashback where he explains how and why he
joined HYDRA.
SHIELD basically took a dump on him after
an operation went sideways and now he’s
out to make them pay.
I keep watching Raina more and more closely
too, because as she learns what Garrett is
really after she and Ward start to distance
themselves from him.
I sense a reckoning, if it weren’t already
plainly obvious that Coulson always wins in
the end.
Number X - Raina and May Foreshadow Transformations
and Releasing Inner Power
This is all about Skye, everyone is wondering
WTF is up with her DNA.
Raina is coming at it from a metahuman perspective.
All that talk about “what’s on the inside
revealing itself” is just a clear indicator
that Skye and Raina are going to morph into
alien or superhuman form during the finale.
I’m going to stick with my two possibilities
for Skye, either she’s straight up Frost
Giant, like the monsters Raina mentioned or
she’s Kree.
Either way both her parents were aliens.
So she isn’t half anything, she is 100%
Kree or Skrull or Frost Giant.
I think it would be badass if she were a Skrull,
it would explain the human form.
Actually let’s go with that.
You’re friendly neighborhood Skrull.
and my Number 1 WTF Moment - Garrett Takes
The Serum
Glowy skin equals not good for Team Coulson.
We saw him punch Coulson across the room in
the teaser for next week.
So I’m guessing that he’s just healed
and super strong.
And super crazy.
I expected him to manifest some physical deformity,
but the minute Raina produced that vial I
knew there was no way Garrett was NOT going
to take it himself.
That’s all he cares about himself.
And why would she give it to him if she’s
pissed he’s such a deusche?
She’s curious and wants to see what comes
out.
Just like with Skye.
She kept looking at her own hand like she
was hiding something special inside herself
too.
Like she’s either a metahuman or she’s
an alien or skrull in disguise.
I full expect the finale to reveal but not
explain what Skye is.
They’ll probably save the deeper exploration
of her heritage for season 2 and beyond.
That feels like a Willow Buffy thing, where
she developed her powers over the course of
a few seasons.
Not all at once.
But let me know what your biggest WTF moment
was?
And do you think Ward killed buddy the dog?
I don’t think he did.
We never heard that rifle go off.
Overall the episode was back to A minus status.
I loved Maria Hill last week, but this episode
really went a long way to deepening this Skye
Blue Alien plot.
And right now, that’s really the only one
I care about.
I totally expect Brett Dalton to be on the
show in season 2 and even if everyone hates
him, he’ll be back on Team Coulson.
Bill Paxton has been a lot of fun to watch
at times, but I feel like for him, this episode
was just purgatory before he gets to be a
full on supervillain in the finale.
He was amazing as a dirtbag SHIELD Agent and
then an asshole HYDRA Agent.
But this episode was mostly him hobbling around
being taken out by joy buzzer EMPs.
He was literally a fleshbag of fail until
he took the serum.
I always hate those times when characters
are in limbo states.
Either be a man or be a superman.
Don’t sit on the fence.
It’s boring.
Based on all the blue alien, May bottled rage,
Ward and Raina turncoat foreshadowing I feel
like the final battle will be pretty much
all the main characters versus Garrett.
Deathlok too, but they’ll have to fix the
detonator in his brain before he can help
them.
I will say SHIELD has definitely gotten really
good the second half of this season.
I really hope they’re able to build the
momentum for a strong second season.
I know a lot of you have been asking me whether
or not it’s been renewed.
Essentially yes it has, but not officially.
They will make the official announcement when
they reveal the Agent Carter series.
Right now in Hollywood all the studios are
announcing which shows are getting renewed
and which pilots are going to series.
For instance, the Flash tv show at the CW.
We’ll also officially find out about that
in the next week.
So if there’s anything big I left out of
the video, just write it below in the comments.
And let me know what you think Skye is.
Remember, whatever she is.
She is 100 percent alien.
So you have to account for the fact she can
still look human.
Hint Hint, Super Skrull.
Next week is the finale, so be sure to subscribe
to get my video.
Remember, in two weeks I’ll start doing
regular Star Wars tuesday videos too.
Right now click here for my breakdown of the
new Gotham Trailer and click here for last
week’s episode of SHIELD.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!